bueno si es la quinta mujer acusada de
homicidio por abortos que logran liberar
y para llegar a esta instancia hubo una
larguísima lucha contanos cómo fue todo
ese proceso
buenas noches buenas noches televidentes
claro comentarle el proceso de él y ha
sido una ardua lucha y compleja en el
sentido que desde el 2018 usted solito
te solicita la conmutación de pena de
ella y dan una respuesta de parte del
ministerio de justicia de el salvador
otorgándole la conmutación
reduciéndoles su pena de 30 años a 10
años con 5 meses de y es así como el
juzgado de vigilancia penitenciaria acá
en el salvador comete una mala
interpretación de esta solicitud y
como abogadas defensoras y acudimos a
diferentes métodos para hacer una
apelación en su casa para que ella
pudiera obtener la libertad de manera
inmediata ya que la conmutación de pena
por nada y la pena se sustituyera y se
cambiara es así como ha sido a largos y
contarnos cuál es la situación de otras
mujeres en prisión por situaciones
vinculadas a emergencias obstétricas
evaluadas por la justicia como
homicidios
claro actualmente hay alrededor de siete
mujeres más que cuentan con una
sentencia firme de las cuales estamos
pendientes que el ministerio de justicia
de acá de nuestro país responda cuatro
comunicaciones de pena a favor de estas
mujeres
asimismo interponemos también otros
tipos de beneficios penitenciarios para
que ellas puedan obtener su libertad de
manera inmediata ya que tienen condenas
que son excesivas hasta de 30 a 35 años